un accueil bien spéciale pour ces élèves
de 10 et 11 ans qui sont arrivés de
chine la semaine dernière une chanson de
gilles vigneault et des cerfs-volants
fabriqué pour eux en échange les
nouveaux élèves ont aussi préparé un
cadeau
la moitié du groupe parle déjà français
après avoir passé un an dans une école
de bol ceux là seront intégrés en classe
régulière
les autres iront dans une classe de
francisation pour ceux et celles qui
reviennent
il y a un peu moins d'inconnus j'aime à
la naïve fils sert déjà de la contre
allée des sucreries
la première chose qu alice a demandé
quand est à russes sont des petits
gâteaux vachon et les demi lune à la
vanille oui les contacts virtuels entre
les familles chinoises et les familles
d'accueil sont essentielles et réduisent
un peu le sentiment d'éloignement a
réparé avec ma mère mes parents soro à
peine
c'est comme un pull marin nouvelle sans
rire parce que j'avais pas de sacha
marché juste eu frère la famille de
laurence héberge aussi l'enseignante
chinoise qui passera toute l'année au
québec avec le groupe pour donner une
heure demande arrêts et de mathématiques
par jour après les classes les 20 élèves
viennent de la région de shandong au sud
de pékin leur part anvers 15 mille
dollars pour cette immersion dans une
école publique québécoise vient de
famille c'est bien gentil quand même de
l'école qui est partenaire avec nous
mais non ce n'est pas une charge pour la
commission scolaire ou que trouver de la
place la commission scolaire marguerite
bourgeoys compte déjà 130 5 classes de
francisation
mais ce projet demande un peu plus d'un
extraordinaire projet mais tout le monde
doit participer
puis les gens je pense que tout le monde
était sexiste et depuis des années cette
école de pierrefonds a tissé des liens
avec la chine
et comme ex enseignante de l'école il
avait les manuels n'ont pas hésité à
ouvrir leurs maisons quand on finit par
se connaître mais on voit qu'en fait on
on est paré quelque part même si à la
barrière de la langue qui ne sais pas
ici anne louise despatie réseau canada
pierrefonds